hi eric
thanks for streaming i think you're a
great person and i love your content be
happy that's kind ease
thanks so much
mr chess hat
i think you're a great hat
oh okay
we have fisher random
um
this will be interesting
so yeah people are more than welcome to
challenge me to variants
i have no idea who i'm playing and i
don't know what their rating is so
for all i know this could be magnus
carlsen
or it could be a complete noob
but i'll have to treat it somewhat
seriously
and
i'll just try and follow basic
principles
wait
reload
i don't think the sound setting updated
so unfortunately i can't really play
like typical opening theory
but even in chess 960 like opening
principles still apply i control the
center
i want to find some piece harmony so i'm
thinking this and this and this
resembles some sort of london actually
so bishop here
this is a typical situation in london
like do i take do i retreat
i could play d6 as well
it'll play this move
and the event of takes takes and the
file opens
there might be some long term pressure
especially if i get a queen bishop
battery
it's a rare yellow arrow
if you want to challenge me we do have a
challenge command
for anyone new here
exclamation point challenge click the
link
and uh
and yeah then be patient
because the random algorithm will
determine our fate
okay um play this move
now i'm not even sure what my 960 rating
is
uh
i think it like the the reading scale is
a bit different for 960.
quack
oh i should improve one of my knights
maybe this move
hitting the pawn
my d-pawn's still well supported
i mean white's playing very reasonable
so far
i'm guessing like 18 1900
but it feels like i have a slight
positional advantage i can play this
move
yeah
or maybe takes
we trade
choices choices
and this is actually very committal
[Music]
but let's do it
because it takes away the e3 square from
the knight
and it wins connect four
and this bishop is kind of sad
now i think the plan is to
to play c4 and just
break down the
structure although it's not not so easy
maybe b5
maybe it is so easy b5 and
if white takes and i i trade rooks take
uh back on b5 and get the knight to c3
hey it's r beasley welcome back
happy two years
and calvin and lock summing for three
months in advance appreciate that
yeah i hope all of you are doing well
um
this is a viewer challenge stream
i
suggest challenge me to anything 10
minutes or less
so anything like correspondence probably
would get aborted
oh what to do
knight c6
and c4
[Music]
we'll play this move
yeah i'm guessing like 1900 because
white hasn't made any obvious blunders
and it's requiring more like longer term
strategy to
to play for a win here
i'm realizing white can castle i think
right yeah white hasn't moved the king
or the rook
yeah castling king's side wow
this is not gonna be easy to win
i'm thinking c3
wait is there increments
there's no increment oh i gotta move
faster
and develop the bishop
and the position is so so closed
so i've lost casting rights on the king
side
but okay i'm playing king c7 to enable
rook 8
and i'm going to challenge the a file
and hopefully take over the a file
one of the issues for white is the c
pawn
potentially week after night b4
like long term night before knight a3
this is the base of the pawn chain
start with this move
okay
mission accomplished
and yeah i have uh queen a2 and knight
a3 so three potential attackers
but white has this move in this move so
[Music]
this could get interesting
wow
oh okay after knight e1
queen b2
and my paw my connect 5 pawn chain takes
away all the squares from the queen
white has nothing better to take and
then i promote like i'm just winning a
queen here
or trading greens and then making a new
queen
and this move completed the connect 6.
that's kind of nice
uh
yeah
oh no my
knight oh this bishop defended though
yeah i'll maneuver in the night uh
towards the center
cool game to start the stream
i'm still guessing like 1900 like white
played a
i think play the fine game just got kind
of ground down
like i transformed the space advantage
into a material advantage
still have to avoid flagging
it looks dangerous to put my queen like
surrounded by white pieces but
okay i'm hitting this threatening queen
e2 rick
36 minutes in oh no nice streak
well now i'm competing with myself for
stephen gray's attention
or competing with my past self
i want to play g5 mate but there's on
poisson
i guess there's g5 check
ah g5 and then white flags
okay final guess 1900
[Music]
but chess 960 rating maybe 1800 or 1850
could be over 2 000 though not sure
okay 1900
let's see
oh i was playing lone wander
who's provisional
in 960.
yeah it's cool game because white didn't
make any any blunders this game it was
just maybe a couple mistakes
yeah maybe f5 the issue with f5 is it
it basically relieved the tension on the
center
and made d5 uh quite strong
um
engine wants a4 here
hey it's photochest
appreciate the raid for maria
shout out to photochess